all right it's Friday again and it's
time for another movie retrospective and
we're doing another John Carpenter movie
and this was one that because you know
how I often say oh I don't really like
any jungle
it's like hitter after they live right I
had totally forgotten about this one and
this one is rad yeah it's got like
Creepshow yeah it's his version of
Creepshow it's body bags
yeah I'm 1993 yeah carpenter even kind
of like hosts it in the way like the
Cryptkeeper day yeah except not as
annoying he's quite cool as a host
really he's like in a woody called in a
morgue should be some kind of more
messing around bodies but he's he's
pretty cool I liked it and it's three
stories and each one of them is pretty
good Cheston isn't edit but it's got a
lot of cameos there's a lot of people
you're like man one of the best things
about this movie and like it was done in
a way that wasn't super cheesy yeah you
know what I mean it was just kind of
like hey here's that and I'm like hey
there's that person and hey there's that
person yeah it's like out of the blue
there's Deborah Harry you know what that
was super was it wasn't even like oh
[ __ ] man there's Mark Hamill yeah and
he's playing like a psychopath yeah
which he was really good at yeah I
thought was that was a little strange
yeah yeah so initially the thing about
body bags it was supposed to be you know
cuz Tales from the Crypt was so popular
for HBO I think it was now I believe it
was Showtime and they approached John
Carpenter about doing a similar series
or they wanted to make like an anthology
type of thing so he made body bags
originally for cable television all
right but then they decided that they
didn't want it so then he was like well
I'll just release it like a theatrical
release okay that's what this came from
right so it was initially intended to be
like the other cable channels version of
Tales from the Crypt so it's like three
stories like I said it's very similar to
creep show yeah you know what Mike
whitus comic book II but a similar type
of thing taking it back to those days
that concept was kind of oversaturated
so maybe that's why they didn't want
another it might have been yeah and be
where they saw it yeah yeah I mean they
weren't that's the thing they weren't
that much of a success I mean mostly in
retrospective you know like don't you
know me oh yeah and I have to say we
eventually will have to do creep show
because I love creep show yeah it's not
the second one the second one's kind of
shitty but the first one was really good
if this has like a similar it's not
quite as comic book II this freak show I
mean it is a horror comedy
although it's not I didn't really find
it as a knee yeah Tales from the Crypt
it's kind of like the movies yeah it's
kind like a carpenter movie when a
carpenter's hit I think he did pretty
good
fairly gory yeah um you know so but I
don't think that that was the the
problem or why Showtime didn't want it
because Tales from the Crypt was pretty
[ __ ] gory - yeah but yeah this was
like it's okay so it's an anthology film
from 1993 its consists of three stories
now the first one is called the gas
station yeah and this one has Robert
Carradine is in it yeah who was in
Revenge of the Nerds mm-hmm it also has
David Norton who was in an American
world from London yeah Sam Raimi makes a
cameo appearance sort of oh yeah yeah
that's right
yeah yeah another person that makes a
cameo appearance as like shifty creep is
Wes Craven that's right actually really
cracks me up a lot yeah each one of
these stories has a bunch of carpenter's
friends make an appearance you know Greg
Nicotero and stuff yeah there's a bunch
of famous people in this yeah so yeah so
the first one is just like basically
this girl and she's it's her first day
on the job and she's doing like the
overnight shift at this remote gas
station and it's just like all these you
know weirdos that she's dealing with
yeah it's kind of like what it's
actually like working that's what I was
gonna stay like you know my dad used to
work in a magic market for many years on
the overnight shift yeah I have friends
that did it
getting held up and I'll tell you one
thing you know it was a trip watching
that particular store is that the gas
stations actually had a service station
connected to it when's the last time
you've seen that yeah that's been I went
looking for one to get a tire changed
and they just they're not around anymore
like I said and it's one of those kind
of things it's one of those kind of
things like you know phone booths yeah
where you just you saw them and then you
didn't really think about it and now you
can't find our line anymore now you get
kind of faded away while you weren't
paying attention and I think the same
thing happened with like service yeah
it's like the dealerships took overall
service yeah you know you can you can go
to tire chain to maybe or yes oh yeah
like now everything is like a big chain
like yeah boys or you know Sears Auto
centers do they even have those anymore
I don't know series no I don't think
they have no they don't have Sears Auto
Center yeah but they still have Pep Boys
and jab that so and I think anyways just
I think most Pep Boys just buying par
stuffy and simply right oh that's right
no there's a pet boy over over there no
that yeah there's that they're all over
the place and they have they have a big
store where you can buy auto parts and
they have a big service yeah [ __ ] too
cuz that's where I used to take my car
when I looked but that's weird you know
when you're when it when you're our age
and our 40s and you see this service
station it just kind of brings back
memories you know like man I remember
when all gas stations look like that
yeah it'll look like that anymore
yeah it's pretty weird gas station
nowadays looks like a convenience store
yeah with some pumps out in front of it
that's pretty much it yeah but yeah so
but like I said all of these stories are
good honestly this one was good I love
Wes Craven coming up like playing it's
over weirdo like this poor girl it is
[ __ ] gas station yeah we can't room I
don't know yeah I'm not gonna ruin it
I'm just doing it various actually I
don't think most people have seen these
and you can watch it for free on to b2b
TV which is tapi dot TV yeah you guys
where's yeah some of the ones that we've
been watching recently we actually found
on to be TV which I actually got turned
on to by a friend of ours because they
said oh the tenant is on there because
we did a show off the tenant and they
said oh it's on there and I was like
what is that they're like it's just this
free [ __ ] it's like Hulu used to be
before only went to an all pay service
yeah and it
and actually they're in HD when they can
and the nice thing yeah there are
commercial breaks in it but not many
it's pretty much just one commercial
every you know 20 30 minutes something
like that yeah and so it's not really
that big a deal the movies are not cut
and the cool thing about them is that
they tend to focus on older movies it's
like you have some newer direct-to-dvd
crabbed and stuff but especially in the
horror section they have a lot of horror
movies and they have a lot of like kind
of classics from the 60s 70s yeah it's
like the older stuff that you don't see
on Netflix it yeah I mean they have a 10
in one day they're changing them all
kind of like [ __ ] on there so they
have Alice sweet Alice they're gonna do
that show and also they have they have
the in the action flicks section they
got all the cheesy ones like the new
Steven Seagal ones that you would not
what you wouldn't want to Bob they
didn't even come out in my favor yeah
yeah DirecTV you don't want to buy that
[ __ ] but you might want watching just a
laugh at it yeah so that's a good place
for that kind of stuff
yeah so that's where we actually saw
body bags and I had totally forgot about
this movie and so I take it back what I
said about John Carpenter not making any
good movies after they live because they
live was what 88 right yeah this one was
93 and I actually really really like
this movie yeah it's kind of hilarious
now the next of the second one I think
was your favorite right it's just called
hair
yeah hair was awesome Stacy Keach isn't
it yeah and he basically plays this guy
who's going bald and his girlfriend is
played by Sheena Easton yeah like I
couldn't play sir wise I'm like who is
that I know who that is but then I
looked it up later yes Sheena Easton
yeah and so he's like super super
sensitive about losing his hair so he
goes to this newfangled clinic that he
sees advertise on late-night TV or some
[ __ ]
it's run by David Warner and his nurse
Debbie Harry that's right and you know
they hair this miracle hair growth and
they don't really tell you what it is
yeah it's a cool story the best thing
about this segment is when the hair
grows he has this fabulous like Fabio
hair yeah
like the king you know make sure my men
are well-fed it's like it's hysterical
and Stacy Keach is so good in that role
and the other eyes all these he tries
all these hokey hair loss cures versus
like painting his scalp a yeah and kind
of like that's what Steven Seagal does
if you look at Steven Seagal he's just
got painted oh she's like back in the
day what's that like Seiberling Hair
Club for Men didn't they do that there
was some hell no it was like a spray
that was like it was spray paint they
had a bunch of different ones one of
them was is they would just take plastic
fake hair they had a barb on it yeah and
they would inject that into your scalp
I'm a guy that invested that that
invented that yeah he got sued because
your hey cuz it would give you a really
bad rash well obviously but you know it
made sense you had silicone implants for
women yeah why not implant a silicone
piece of hair right and yet you can put
more in there maybe you should just like
shave all your hair off
we had to hair onto the top of that
thinking that you could probably revive
that idea with modern technology and
probably get that to work you know I
think do you have that like I don't
really know what the you know I want to
decide bald so I don't I'm not I'm not
up on the edge of hair another thing I
do if they just did they just weave a
net to your head yeah and then weave
synthetic hair or real hair onto that
net right that's that's another so it's
sort of like a wig but it doesn't sound
like a wig but it's woven into your hair
yeah and honestly one and I forgot to
mention but one of the funniest cameos
in this part of it is before Stacy Keach
goes and gets the treatment he's like
looking at all these people with their
fabulous long hair in the tree and Greg
Nicotero is in there yes I get 27 years
old yeah he's very young in this
he's like swishing his hair around like
he's in a [ __ ] Pantene commercial
it's funny he's in it for like two
seconds that's carpenter John Carpenter
in his generation where they really love
to have that long hair that's super
retro nowadays that
it's not really cool you know too much
work it depends how you wear I guess it
depends on who the guy is and what the
hair looks like and what yeah he stole
some people actually look good with long
skinny if you ask me
yeah they give me tall and skinny yeah I
do that definitely helps because then
you can pull off that vampire are Mons
come here well yeah I was gonna say
about Greg Nicotero even though he's
basically known as a makeup guy he was
like you know Tom Savini is protege who
was actually done very well for himself
obviously he does the walking dead and
all that [ __ ] now but um he was in wow
man one of the Romero movies David ed
Don the dead using one of those that got
ripped off I remember that because I
remember watching and if you other you
old other old people maybe remember this
back in the day back in the 80s there
used to be a documentary about Tom
Savini
talking about his special effects I
can't bear the title was I used to have
it on VHS and I watched it a million
times and he's there with Greg Nicotero
who's like 19 or something like that
[ __ ] and he's like his assistant right
and they're talking about like making
the fake head for Greg Nicotero for one
of the zombie movies and [ __ ] like that
it's a good documentary somebody
probably put it on you did by now but
it's just funny seeing Greg Nicotero so
young because now he's just kind of like
an elder statesman type of thing but
yeah so he makes a pretty short cameo in
that as does Sheena Easton like I said
yeah and then the third segment is just
called I yeah it's weird and this is a
pretty standard horror movie type of
story where it's like you know you get a
an organ transplant from somebody it
turns out was murder and then you start
acting like the murderer and stuff like
that yeah it's Mark Hamill he's a he's a
baseball player he's playing a
professional baseball player who gets in
a car wreck and loses an eye yeah so
they transplanted high into his head and
it's a different color and turns out
that it was from a guy who was executed
yeah and he was a psychopath right and
he goes he goes pretty [ __ ] berserk
and it's pretty neat
yeah he starts seeing things that the
killer saw in a way so like I said
that's a pretty standard horror movie
trope I mean the [ __ ] the pang
brothers made that may
that movie that I in 2002 that was kind
of the same same premise yeah she was
seeing dead people I found out that Mark
Hamill is actually a pretty good actor
he was really upsetting ly good in that
yeah because you know she has star wars
start besides Star Wars I'd really only
seen him in the Guyver and you know what
does that Corvette summer I never saw
that one I saw him it was Ivor and the
Guyver is pretty bad well see the thing
about Mark Hamill is that well he kind
of went off in a voice acting I mean
obviously he's like a legendary they say
he's the best joker oh yeah and he's so
he's kind of more known for that than
movie roles but he was really
surprisingly good in this and especially
playing the role that he's playing where
he's just kind of like at first he's
like this aw shucks kind of yeah nice
guy and then he slowly like starts
unraveling me more simulation
psychopathy a morphs into this evil
redneck like I'm Mississippi redneck
yeah kind of like yeah some somebody
from the living in a shotgun Shack way
about out in the woods what he sounds
like
yeah he does a pretty good the accent
kinda yeah yeah so uh other cameos and
this one they were interesting now
here's another thing like his wife in
this it was bugging me the whole time
I'm like god I know her I know her you
know that was Twiggy yeah that's right
you know the very famous model and it
girl from the 60s that was Twiggy two of
the doctors that are working on his eye
are played by Roger Corman obviously the
very famous I forgot about that and
[ __ ] John agar he was in a whole
bunch of shitty Roger Corman movies but
like I didn't recognize him because he's
old as [ __ ] in this movie yeah I I
recognize him from like all the old
fifties movies but he was on an MS t
coz-theta like bust his balls all the
time a president I believe that get an
actor but yeah so John Eggers and this
is one of the doctors yeah the movie has
an all-star cast it really does yeah and
it should say at the end like the kind
of the framing device the
as John Carpenter he's kind of in makeup
somebody looks like a creepy corpsey
attendant kind of thing and he's got
like bags of guts and shows that reminds
me of Beetlejuice yeah he looks a little
bit losing that part not quite as crazy
but the two other morgue attendants are
played by Tom Arnold and tobe Hooper
director of Texas Chainsaw Massacre
among many other things yeah this was
like a star-studded production oh no
they don't make a huge deal now you'd
have to know who they were they're
mostly you know producers and directors
and yeah I said it did stuff behind the
scene but you know if you're if you're a
hardcore horror fan you would pretty
much recognized me yes because I
recognized pretty much everybody and the
ones that I didn't recognize them but I
couldn't remember who they were like
Sheena Easton what you know I was like
man who is that [ __ ] and then like
later I was like oh yeah sure she's a
lovely person
but and same with Twiggy like I didn't
write like you know who she was but I
couldn't place her yeah I never would
have known that was Twiggy but yet the
funny until all the directors I
recognized yeah the Greg Nicotero one
made me laugh the most just because of
his [ __ ] hair flying yes but yes so I
kind of feel like this movie pretty well
regarded these days it's got on Rotten
Tomatoes it's got about 78% fresh rating
which is you know that's what you can't
always go by that but if you've got a
good rating a lot of times it's alright
there's a lot of [ __ ] up there that has
a bad rating I'm going what the hell
they talking about that's a pretty cool
movie yes you know it's a thing a taste
I mean movies are so subjective it's
like some people are gonna like one
thing and I have a feeling that like a
lot of the people that actually kind of
give reviews on Rotten Tomatoes there
are younger people so they don't really
they're not seeing the movie in the
context of the time they're trying to
judge it by modern standards a lot of
times cuz oh you know like I'll go back
and I'll read a review written by
somebody on a movie that you know from
the 80s yeah and they're talking bad
about it and I'm like men dude it was it
was 82 what do you expect
they didn't look this thing we didn't
have all the [ __ ] lien has right yeah
you kids today with your CGI yeah how
many that [ __ ] well you did but it was
like really crappy but yeah the thing
about body bags like I said and I feel
bad that I had totally forgotten about
it I really like anthology movies you
know some of them are kind of uneven
especially if it's like a bunch of
different directors and things like that
but I've seen a lot of ones that I
really enjoyed including Creepshow and
including some newer ones too I think
there was one called a Christmas Horrors
or Christmas something or other and that
only came out a couple years ago was it
you watched it with me I think that
right second it had the shat in it it's
like one of the framing devices I've had
Santa fighting Krampus it was that's
pretty rad that's right and I really
liked that one a lot and you know you're
gonna run into that with any anthology
maybe like some of the stories are
better than others but this one since
it's only three yeah they're all good
yeah there are no pretty short they're
all pretty succinct like to the point
and it's funny but it's not like
over-the-top funny yeah you know I mean
it's amusing and it's fun like spotting
all the cameos and [ __ ] like that which
was something that I really enjoyed and
you know I I just really liked it and
like I said I feel bad that I said that
he didn't make it sorry John Carpenter
this one is really good well there was
and the mouth of madness was Beth yeah
that's true and we're gonna have to do
or do don't - in a couple of weeks yeah
that's one of our once that's upcoming
like I said on the last thing we're
doing a we're doing a kind of
Lovecraftian yeah we went off on a
Lovecraftian type of [ __ ] right because
of stuff that was on to be TV and yeah
that I saw and I was like yeah we need
to do reviews of that so that'll be
upcoming alright so that will do it for
our brief review of body bags go check
it out it's on TV TV right now as of
this recording I don't know if they're
gonna take it down later or what but you
know if you want to watch it go watch it
you can watch it free yeah and remember
if you like our show to Like share
subscribe share on all your social media
if you'd like to financially support the
show you can go to our patreon page
which is patreon.com slash 13 o'clock
podcast or you can go to our blog which
is 13 o'clock podcast wordpress.com and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account if you'd rather give a
time donation and also remember to check
out our regular episodes every Tuesday
and our movie reviews which come out
every Friday and we will see you next
time bye